[Musique]
le président du Département Cyril Melkor
a participé ce mardi 6 février à la
remise des diplôme de l'atelier chantier
d'insertion au centre de détention du
port la collectivité a accompagné
l'association éducanou qui a former des
détenus pour préparer leur réinsertion
sociale et professionnelle il n'y a pas
de fatalité il y a parfois des
difficultés à surmontter bien évidemment
c'est pour cela que le département est
là pour accompagner toutes les personnes
qui à un moment donné se disent je veux
m'en sortir je veux aller vers le monde
du travail pour cela j'ai besoin de me
former d'obtenir des qualifications et
lorsque certaines personnes se trouvent
dans le centre pénitentiaire du port et
que l'association duucanou nous propose
des formations pour les amener vers une
qualification et bien le département
répond présent donc moi je salue le
travail de l'association et duucanou je
salue aussi l'ouverture bah de du
directeur de ses équipes et je salue
l'implication des personnes qui au
centre pénitentiaire ben ont décidé de
se former je les félicite et je leur dit
bonne continuation pendant plus d'un an
l'association éeducanous structure
d'insertion par l'activité économique
crée en 2010 a former des détenus au
métier de la restauration des diplômés
très motivés à se réinsérer dès leur
sortie ben c'est l'aboutissement de
d'une année et demi de travail et et
l'espoir de trouver rapidement du
travail une fois que je je serai sorti
c'est essentiel on peut pas sortir de
prison sans envisager c'est obligé c'est
je peux pas me
retrouver sans sans travail ni logement
c'est c'est la base en fait mes
espérances serait évidemment d'être enyé
dans un restaurant
ou en cuisine ou en salle les deux me
conviennent très bien j'ai une nette
préférence pour la
cuisine je pense que je je n'hésiterai
pas à me former dans d'autres
spécialités qu es jeune tu es avec des
entourages tu vas faire n'importe quoi
tu prends la violence et quand tu fais
un tu rentres en détention
ben comme si c'est comme un c'est quoi
je vraiment tu vois vraiment les
importances ben vraiment le monde
extérieur commence à se déroule j'ai
faire un travail surz moi-ême et de
repartir un nouveau un nouveau départ là
c'est ben de recommencer tout à zéro ben
retrouver une formation plus vite pour
être en tant que chef cuisinier ou
traiteur puis être repasser un dipl en
tant
formateur MONUC traiteur et de faire une
formation
comme du les diplômés ont été des élèves
exemplaires tout au long de leur année
de formation et ont dors déjà des pistes
de travail qui les attendent à la
[Musique]
sortie